well my early Slovak video wasn't the
best so let's revisit the topic by
looking at probably the most
historically prominent early Slovak
theory which is the Slavic magnetic
connection also depending on the
translation then they can be spelled
multiple of ways so vanetti were
actually three tribes in history a
celtic tribe living in brittany and
obscure in the european tribe living in
northeastern Italy which is the reason
why today this region is called Veneto
and why Venice is called Venice but I
digress and lastly the vanity living
east of the Vistula River also known as
the Vistula Benanti before we look at
the visual variety we have to address
the fact that there are seemingly three
completely different tribes with the
same name now this is mostly credited to
two things one is that we know the names
of all these tribes because Romans
brought it down and they didn't always
ask the people what they actually called
themself so this could easily just be a
Roman unimaginative naming scheme
reusing names of different tribes in
different areas it's not like the Romans
were particularly known for their TACT's
nests when naming other people another
explanation and also one that could play
a role along with the first explanation
is that vanetti originates from an old
indo-european word meaning it wouldn't
be far-fetched to see multiple
indo-european tribes no matter how far
removed using it however with all that
said what needs to be stressed is that
none of these three vennett ik tribes
had anything in common other than that
they spoke a variation of an
indo-european language with the Britain
vanetti speaking Celtic the Italian
vanetti proto italic and the visual
ability well we don't know so let's look
at the rest when a team the first
mention of the Vistula vanetti comes
from the 1st century ce e in plenties
natural history and all he says is that
they are a sermon teeing group that
lives somewhere near the baltic sea east
of the Vistula not much to go off of
second mention is from taketo since
Germania who also puts divinity somewhat
clumsily east of the Vistula somewhere
near the baltic sea
he also says they have settled homes
carry shields and are fond of travelling
on foot again not much to really go by
he also classifies divinity as a
Germanic tribe but tack is assessed
classifications should be taken with a
grain of salt as he set out in his book
to classify every tribe north east of
Rome as either Germanic or
semantics which means even if the
Vistula vanity we're slavic tacit azad
still classify them as either germanic
or semantics
the last ancient mention of the visceral
vanity comes from the second century
ptolemies geography a' in it Ptolemy
again puts divinity somewhere east of
the Vistula near the Baltic Sea but he
also puts some vanity ad the Baltic Sea
next to the Gulf of Dance and those are
all the ancient sources about the
virtual Verity would the only thing all
three sources agree on being the
location of where the vanity lived and
not even fully as Pliny and tacit us put
the vanity near the Baltic Sea while
ptolemy puts some of the vanity at the
baltic sea wells orders just near it
this could be due to the passage of time
and the fact that Ptolemy was writing
roughly fifty to a hundred years later
from the others meaning that sounds
vanity could have moved into the Gulf of
dance during that time but we just don't
know now that we have established the
baseline from the ancient sources we
have to look at The Smoking Gun of your
will of the Slavic vanity connection
this smoking gun comes in form of a
sixth century Eastern Roman bureaucrat
turned historian Jordana's Jordana's
wrote a book called Gatica
which was a shortened version of a
cassiodorus twelve volume work on the
history of the Goths and because history
is a cruel mistress of course the one
book by Jordana survived and the twelve
volume work by cassiodorus has been lost
a time the statement is made even
further upsetting by the fact that
today's Jordana's is one book is the
only surviving source on the early
history of the Goths we have but wait it
gets even worse even if we disregard the
fact that Jordana says both leaves out a
lot of stuff as it is a summary of a
twelve volume work jordanna's himself
isn't a very good historian he was a
burke rat to start off with and his book
is littered with references to the
contemporary state of politics in
Byzantium even in some passages confuses
the dashians and 3sh ends with the Goths
but despite all these mistakes he still
nonetheless wrote a book which is very
valuable to us and gets a lot of things
correct and in that book there's one
simple line beginning and the source of
the Vistula the populist race of the
vanity 12 occupying a great expanse of
land though their names are now
dispersed I met various clans and places
they are chiefly coats Club
and antis Slovenian auntie's are known
Byzantine names for the slaves being
first used by procopius who with
jordanna's is the first person to ever
mention the Slavs in a written record so
that's it Jordanna said the Slavs were
known previously as the vanetti
hence the ancient vanity were in fact
Slavs right well as you can see by the
length of this video not quite true
Donna's as mentioned before has made
mistakes when classifying other people
groups so naturally we have to be
skeptical of his vanity statement and
have to analyze it in the context of
other sources this is problematic
because jordanna's is the only known
medieval writer to mention that the
Slavs were previously called Benetti
for copious agafia's Joan of malala's
etc none of them ever mentioned that the
Slavs were known as Benanti but this
fact was completely ignored by early
modern slavic historians who took
Jordana's at face value the 19th and
20th centuries of the rise of Slavic
nationalism along with nation-states all
of whom saw the historical connection to
their new movement and historical
accuracy be damned they will find it no
matter what
safarik when is far as to say that all
modern nations must have had an ancestor
in the ancient world a statement which
Jordanna says work was happily
supporting for the Slavs a quick side
note here the Slavic magnetic
connections is actually the most normal
historical thing to come out of this
movement for example it was during this
time that Serbians decided that they
actually lived in the Balkans for 6,000
years or something and absolutely an
accurate statement that I still get
comments about nonetheless this movement
wasn't born from nothing it was part of
a greater reactionary movement trying to
legitimize the Slavic ethnicities to the
Western nations who up until fairly
recently viewed the Slavs as and I quote
an intellectually inferior race of
obscure attic origin this is why the
Slavic vanetti connection was happily
accepted by the Slavs because it not
only gave the Slavs a decisive European
origin but also history dating back to
the Roman era which in their eyes gave
them more legitimacy and since the
slavic vanity connection was now
considered as truth such a truth most
certainly must have an archaeological
proof just waiting to be found so during
most of the 20th century many Slavic
nations exerted a lot of academic effort
towards finding an archeological proof
for as
Vanetta connection including the USSR
who used the connection as a propaganda
piece to stimulate unity amongst the
Slovak communist states as you may have
figured out by now no clear-cut
archaeological connection was found and
to explain it I will have to go on a
very large side note I promise I will
circle back so the earliest Slovak
archaeological culture types dating back
to the late 5th and early six centuries
are defined by this thing's practically
cremation burial etc it's called the
practicode regroup and it is subdivided
into multiple distinct archaeological
cultures archaeological culture types or
material culture types like the various
practical cultures are defined by a
similarity of reoccurring archaeological
materials or observable customs in a
certain area this does not necessarily
mean that archaeological culture types
can always define an actual existing
ethnicity in a certain area as they can
only define greater archaeological
trends after all two different
ethnicities could leave very similar
archeological remnants --is however dug
logic does apply here
meaning if it looks like a duck and it
quacks like a duck it's probably a duck
going back to the various practical
cultures how similar or different they
wear is currently a matter of debate as
relying on pottery isn't the most
accurate therefore people like kurta are
very sceptical at classifying all these
culture types as Slavic however
considering all these practically
culture groups emerge at the same time
as we get the first written record about
the Slavs and their migrations by
procopius and other historians if it
looks like a duck so on I also want to
stress that no historians even Corte
argued that all practically cultures are
in Slavic the debate is whether all the
practical cultures were only Slavic or
if some of them were a mixture of
multiple ethnicities or even some that
being Slavic at all and only just
adopting the customs and Technology of
the culture type nevertheless the
practically cultures if not all at least
some are still the first known debatable
Slavic archaeological culture types so
to understand how we could possibly
connect these archaeological colchester
earlier ones we have to look at the
state of Eastern Europe around the 1st
and 2nd centuries now thanks to
historians like aforementioned Pliny and
tacit us we can very accurately define
the borders and border tribes of the
Roman M
fire but naturally the further out you
go from the borders of the Roman Empire
the harder it gets to define what kind
of tribes lived where because Romans
didn't really write much about them
which leaves us with a lot of one of
mentions of tribes like the vanity so in
that in mind let's look at the three
most important archaeological culture
types to us in the 1st and 2nd century
those being the will part culture the
pressure works culture and Xaro Beansie
culture in the latter half of the second
century we see a very large and
explosive expansion of the will bar
culture into the lands of the Persian
works culture which subsequently moved
more south and sorrow Beansie culture
whose western half gets subsequently
absorbed into the wheel bar culture and
the eastern half pushed more eastwards
where it transformed into the kiev
culture type then at the end of the
second and beginning of the 3rd century
we'll bar culture expanded even more
southward merging with the various erm
antion remnants of zarubin yet and that
same culture types creating a new
culture type the Chania cove the Willmar
culture then even though persisting in
some areas like pomeranian to the 5th
century drastically declined in the 3rd
and 4th centuries the Persia Box culture
type started to decline in the 4th
century and ended in the 5th century the
Cheuk of culture type didn't see much
decline however it also ended abruptly
in the 5th century all I just talked
about right now we're changes and
migrations of archaeological culture
types which has stated before it does
not necessarily mean a migration of
people groups but if we combine these
culture types with historic records a
certain pattern starts to emerge first
the migration of Goths started at the
mouth of the Vistula
well maybe Scandinavia but we don't have
time to get into that debate 2nd south
of the Gulf's world vandals third the
Goths attack the Vandals and maybe other
Germanic tribes who then exerted
pressure on the tribes bordering Rome
who then under this pressure started the
Roman Marco Manik Wars and 166 to 180
all of this dating coincides with the
will bar culture pushing of pressure
Wars culture more southward 4th when the
Vandals emerged in Pannonia it was from
the area of the Persian works culture
plus they said they came to Pannonia
because Goths pushed them their faith in
the 3rd century Goths established a
political entity in southern Ukraine
from which they conducted their first
raid into Rome in 236 and only ramped up
from there this timing coincides with
the Cheuk of culture type emergence in
southern Ukraine 6th of these culture
types as mentioned before seem to end
all
at the same time in the 5th century
which is the time when the Huns arrived
in Central Europe lastly there's the
fact that runic inscriptions and Elder
Futhark were found in areas dominated by
wheel bark China Cove and Persia Works
cultures so in the end if it looks like
a duck you get my point
now all of this is not without its
caveats for example the Persia works and
Cheuk of cultures existed way after
Goths and vandals went and basically
helped the Roman Empire to end plus both
of these culture types had certain other
characteristics pressure works had not
only Germanic but also some savage and
Celtic and other characteristics while
Chekhov also had not only Germanic but
also some Slavic some antion and in the
western half Dacia characteristics but
remember these are archaeological
culture types they again don't
necessarily mean the movement of people
groups for example the pressure works
culture type could have easily been
started by the Vandals but after they
left it could have continued with the
different people groups that they left
behind or maybe some vandals decided to
stay behind or the culture type could
have been adopted by people who came in
after the Vandals or most likely all of
these factors played a role all at once
we just don't know exactly in the end I
with many other historians are just
pointing out the certain patterns that
can be seen in the archaeological
culture type movements when combined
with the written records
you
but what does any of these Germanic
migrations and archaeological cultures
have to do with the Slavic magnetic
connection well all of these culture
types mentioned have at one point or
another being called Slovak and being
called the remnants of the Slovak
vanetti
which for some of these cultures is
completely ridiculous because the check
of culture isn't even near the Baltic
Sea the will bar culture doesn't have
any Slavic characteristics and the Kiev
culture is near the Dnieper not the
Vistula etc but when you look at the
people who peddled these statements it
becomes clear it's a nationalistic issue
Western Jakov culture being promoted by
Ukrainians and Russians Persia works and
will bar cultures by poles and so on
however if you look past all this to
culture tabs seem to emerge desire
vignettes and later Kiev Kiev is at this
point pretty much accepted to be a
predecessor to the Slavic practice
pottery culture as the area and was
located and as also the area where the
oldest practically culture materials
were found but what is debated is if the
Kiev culture emerged from zero vignettes
like I have previously mentioned maybe
linguistics can help us find an answer
to this when it comes to the Slavic
linguistics two very influential works
are bio stuff in ski and robochav Rostov
in ski was the first person to notice
that all sewing languages like certain
words that relate to seafaring or
particular plants like large and new
instead all Slavic languages use bold
words from mainly Germanic but also
sometimes Latin or some Anton languages
to describe these plans or seafaring
actions this means that the Slavic
language evolved in a landlocked area
where the Slavs didn't have access to
the sea and plans like larger you didn't
exist such an area in fact does lie in
Europe and it's called policia just
straddling the Belarusian and Ukrainian
border and a bit of Poland this
coincidentally is also where does a
Tobias culture and later partly Kiev
culture existed
rhasta Fiske II was then supported in
this by Trueba Jeff who found the oldest
Slavic Hydra names and toponyms north of
the upper nester and west of the middle
nyet and this is where I will mention
our last archaeological source that I
have been saving until now Co belinskiy
a Polish archaeologist brought about the
occurrence and spread of health warts in
Eastern Europe he showed that in Poland
the characteristic Slavic hillford
settlements didn't occur before the 6th
century however after the 6th century we
can see spread of these hill forts
across Poland eastern Germany etc and
these health words came to Poland you
guessed it from polizia
can be dated to as far back as the
second century some of these forts were
also found in Northland knepper which
could be due to the forest move out of
Venus culture more eastwards by the
wheel bark culture
interestingly these hill forts and
polizia seem to originate from Latvia
where the fort's can be dated as far
back as the 5th century BCE this
evidence could may be linked to about
the slavic tribe after all Baltic is the
closest language relative to Slavic and
the indo-european family tree but in the
end this is hard to tell the further
back you go the less evidence there is
and the more possibilities there are but
taking the last stated fact aside for
now the linguistic evidence the
archaeological evidence and the spread
of health words across Europe from
polizia around the same time when
written records tell us of a slavic
migration does seem to support the
Slavic presence in said area before the
emergence of the Kiev culture type
meaning the Serbians culture is most
likely Slavic this culture type existed
during the same time as the vanetti were
said to exist in an area which is east
of the Vistula but not really near the
Baltic Sea where the vanity were said to
live however there is still one more
linguistic puzzle piece that needs to be
looked at the Germanic word to denote
the Slavs in the Middle Ages was vendor
or vendor or event but most notably gist
vents which does seem very close to the
name vanetti this is why many proponents
of the Slavic magnetic connection point
to this fact as to prove that the
vanetti were slaves otherwise why would
the Germanic people call the Slavs bens
well it is not uncommon for tribes in
history to adopt the name of the tribe
that lived in the area before them plus
it's not like the vanity if they were in
Slavic would have just disappeared
suddenly no they would have been just
absorbed into the Slavic population over
time so calling the sauce vanity
wouldn't have been completely wrong
lastly there are no early sources for
the Slavs actually calling themselves
vanity or events in the early stages the
word events was only used by Western
Germanic chroniclers to classify the
Slavs
not by slaves themselves which would
further support the fact that the
Germanic chroniclers just adopted the
name of the former tribe that was on
their eastern border to describe the new
tribe that was on their eastern border
looking at all the evidence especially
linguistic and archaeological it looks
like jordanna's was just wrong as most
things point our to Slavs being in
polizia therefore in the early 21st
century after the pan-slavic idealism
propaganda had passed many historians
started to view the Slavic magnetic
connection as wrong harkening back to
the words of the first denier of the
Serenity connection Yosef dubrovsky who
in 1818 said that Jordana's just named
the husband ante because he found them
living in an area where the ancient
Benanti lived not because of any actual
ethnic connection but where the vanity
truly not Slavic well it depends first
is that we don't know the exact extent
of the area the vanity lived in East of
the Vistula near the Baltic Sea can be
interpreted multiple ways and many
people put the vanity as far as polizia
at which point if the vanity were really
that big most of the facts seem to point
ours the vanity being Slavic however at
the same time the sentence can be
interpreted literally with the vanity
only living exact least of the Vistula
near the Baltic Sea at which point the
vanity being Slavic is very unlikely as
most linguistic sources and no
archaeological sources support it but
that brings us to the second point which
i think is often overlooked and it is
the most likely one I call this point
people have sex with anyone the nice
political boundaries of the modern world
we are used to today didn't exist for
most of history a lot of tribes lived
amongst each other and with each other
trying to define an exact area where the
Germanic surmounting Celtic Slavic
tribes lived as impossible people moved
people lived with one another people
procreated with one another etc of
course there were areas where only one
tribe was but there were many
overlapping areas so with that in mind
the reason why most of Slavic evidence
seems to point out it's Malaysia is
because that was the largest and most
homogeneous area where the Slavs lived
however at the same time the certain
Slavic characteristics found in the
Cheuk of culture type show a presence of
some Slavic tribes even though the
culture tab has more Germanic and some
antion traits same goes with the
pressure works culture type and maybe
even more that we haven't discovered yet
creating a gradient of early Slavic
settlement and this logic should be
applied to not just slaves but also
Germanic tribes and sir Monti and etc so
the vanetti who even the ancient sources
had trouble classifying due to their
mixed nature seem to have been a mix of
multiple tribes which most likely
included saws but it doesn't seem like
the Slavs were the majority
with the vanetti being most likely a
Germanic slobbing mix with some Baltic
and Sur mantheon members
being overall part of the Persia Works
culture type then after the Hoenig
arrival and their political / social
disruption in much of Europe pushing
many of the Germanic groups westwards
the stage was set for the Slavic culture
types to emerge and then freely expand
after the herding Federation fell apart
with the vanetti during this tumultuous
time being absorbed into the greater
Sabich ethnicity and the name being
adopted by Western Germanic chroniclers
to now describe just the Slavs lastly
I'm going to address the topic every
layman slavic historian loves to talk
about because I always give comments
about it and that is genetics genetics
are incapable of proving precise
movements of ethnicities first it's
because ethnicity is a social construct
that person's genetics cannot tell you
about like for example if a person and
Roman NGO thought of himself as Roman or
Celtic second because genetics operate
and show a much larger time scale of
thousands of years rather than hundreds
or dozens that the migrations were
talking about occurred in third European
genetic makeup is far more similar than
Europeans would like to believe after
all most of us speak a variation of an
indo-european language I will conclude
with this statement from a Polish
genetic study the formation of
contemporary European ethnic groups
including the Slavs is a relatively
recent process recent on a genetic
timescale
therefore mitochondrial DNA analysis
that did not allow identification of any
specific features which would clearly
distinguish Slavs from the other
European populations and I know we'd
only talked about mitochondrial DNA
haplogroups here but the same applies to
y-chromosome haplogroup all of this is
not to say that genetic studies aren't
valuable it's just that they are in a
smoking gun and should be used only as
another piece of a greater puzzle
especially when dealing with prehistory
however as stated in this case DNA study
sadly cannot help us
that was a long one I have been working
on this video since November
hopefully it is much better than my
previous Slavic origins video there's a
lot of things I wanted to talk about
that I just didn't have the time for
like the history behind some of the
Slavic world words or the so-called
parents egg size on the thumbnail of
this video or the various runic
inscriptions found in Eastern Europe or
the overlapping / adoption of
archaeological culture types and the way
we can tell that some practically
culture finds weren't left behind by
Slavs or how some Slavs adopted stupid
practices or how we know that some Slavs
were present at the honey court through
Slavic long words written by Romans who
thought they were Hunnic etc however I
have a limited amount of time and the
video can only be so long so as always
my scripts with all the sources are
available for free on patreon there's
more information clarifications and
corrections in the pinned comment you
can support me on patreon and as always
if you want to see more videos like
these click the bell icon and subscribe
my name is Emma lazer and stick around
for history